all right we're going truffle hunting
with that gold today we're exploring the
city of hula we have a beautiful
applicator right behind us we're about
to go it is
[Music]
beautiful
this is so cool it wasn't built around
the same time as the Colosseum in Rome
but it's pretty awesome because the
entire exterior of this place is
original everything inside not
everything but a lot of it was
replicated because people took stones
away to build health homes and
apparently there was a lot of different
countries that have been here in pula
and that they would use this arena for
many different things google it
[Music]
beautiful so the last few days we've
been seeing the green part of Austria
because it's been a forest and like the
pills and the green nature now we get to
see the blue nature because now we're by
the ocean we're gonna be staying by the
ocean so it's pretty nice this is so
cute we live in a little town like this
little village where we know everyone
but - the tourists so it can't be like
well no yeah close it off to ourselves
this place is so classical and cute just
like you ah we and I was not expecting
that
[Music]
all right we are now at our next hotel
yes that's how hotel is on this trip
Ravel my boutique hotel it's so gorgeous
and resume and already it's right on the
beach that's more about one of the
combinations work I feel like I'm
infinity wall because everything's white
look at this this is so beautiful look
at this way to go lighting on the bed -
or under the bed it's so romantic
this place is gorgeous
oh my gosh and then look at the
beautiful we wake up to be bit this is
on the
can we see that can we camera catch that
the lighting it's so beautiful it's like
heaven like we're literally in heaven
guys I cannot believe it what's the name
we look at the neighbors sitting on us
we're in novigrad that's the name of the
city - good I deserve it good for you
then it's like Miami over there like the
Sun is right behind the clouds look like
a easy
Sabrina's looking up too much eating
this is probably the
we've ever been
yeah I think you'll be the shove cares
off the top spot I had no idea I'm so
where you were invited out here because
I didn't even know its really existed
I never even knew that I never fathomed
in my life I would ever be here
[Music]
anniversary trip she got married in
Croatia and then be true so nice yeah I
want to try cheese mousse like that's
like mashed potatoes a bit smoother and
cheesy that's what they should put in
mozzarella stick right there this is
like the most expensive mozzarella stick
ever
[Music]
all the flavors of the rainbow Beavis
write what you think what you think
rather really fluttery
I love how crispy the skin is - yeah
it's like the hardest thing to cook at
home because we have terrible pans and
so when I tried doing that the new pans
the skin just falls off completely
and it burns oh yeah Anna's really bulky
so and with like really light fish
gaining weight for sure on this trip so
funny because I've been seeing a lot of
comments with like you guys better be
making a baby out of this trip kind of
like with Martin do that after their
Europe trips or making babies food
babies that's exactly what we're making
we're in the future baby where you go
sleep in the future come join me
I just want to go to see really you have
to wake up early in the future he tests
in the future
[Music]
so you don't forget they're saying that
this is the most beautiful town not just
Istria but all of Croatia was the most
romantic town ever and we just got here
and I can tell you I already agree
romantic
I'm like blocking you in my hat
[Laughter]
I can tell you the camera does not go
justice never at all never know even for
future to memories girl you're wishing
right now leave your bike right here
enjoy this evil being through the sea
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
like a true sailor man
I actually need this
that's my favorite color in the water in
front of me beautiful and I just like a
perfect blue like perfect blue
take it home
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
again again again either so pretty
[Music]
with gorgeous restaurant and it's right
in front of the ignition that's such a
gorgeous view for lunchtime
but I do want to speak you don't speak
favorite happy like that be like every
time we eat it's probably because it's a
super fresh out here yeah hey brother
bathing suits and everything to son here
but I wanted to touch the water first
before changing into my bathing suit cuz
what it gets too cold again and yeah
it's a little too cold for me but
everyone seems to be having a really
nice time getting like refreshed and
cooled off it's 83 degrees here so it's
warm enough to want to get in some cold
water but not for me
[Music]
I was just kind of trying to get lost
these beautiful streets of routine
gorgeous every single Street like every
turn we make it was just beautiful that
duck was
[Music]
[Music]
now we're gonna have dinner perfect
sunset hour for dinner
it was beautiful restaurant by the ocean
[Music]
under olive oil we put olive oil and
everything I'm doing that when you get
home everything
[Music]
today we're walking through the town of
pottage it's this beautiful quaint
little town and then right after we're
gonna be heading to this thing it's like
a press conference with the whole
Tourism Board of Croatia so that's kind
of exciting we've never done anything
like that but for now we're just walking
around the town and soaking in its
quaint beautifulness this we get a red
carpet we're so special just getting a
breath
[Music]
[Music]
this beautiful fancy canopy
[Music]
fancy super fancy I'm feeling so
important - this is fun how we didn't
get the area canopies at our wedding
oh yeah we get to enjoy it now yeah and
you know I'm wearing a blue jacket
you're wearing white redux right so
we're having lunch and one of the media
outlets that were at the press
conference today published their article
already and then here we are where the
influencers at the event
that's so funny we had us pose with our
tools tools tools hey what's your tool
my phone mm-hmm
it's so funny seeing yourselves in a
Croatian website publication media
outlets
[Music]
I'm gonna miss smell your breath we
doing about to have our last dinner in
Istria and apparently it's an epic
dinner because they're saying it's gonna
be like five six courses or something I
know but I'm really excited I think this
is a michelin-rated restaurant so
beautiful so right now we were just
taking photos and they're still thinking
but it's just being interviewed by a
journalist I was like being interviewed
by the history and media though it was
so cool I've never been interviewed by a
journalist before I know it's really
cool having Diane would be my my
translator that was pretty cool
I'm like how I think of them flows
perfect bored sigh we stuttered my words
especially when I'm under pressure my
mind goes blank
yes we're pretty cool today's been epic
I think my favorite thing about walking
away from this experience with learning
about a new region of the world that I
didn't even know existed until coming
here because I honestly have no idea
what it really was I'm like is this tree
up like a dumb country or is it like
what like it's just like a like those
secret gem in the world for me and so it
was so awesome to have the opportunity
to thanks to you guys
tourism board hit hit me up and said
everyone you want to bring you up here
and show you a little part of the world
and it brings so incredible I'm like so
eternally grateful for that grateful to
the tourism workers with you guys and
just this whole experience and
eye-opening
it's literally my dream come true like
you have no idea I'm so happy like I'm
so happy
happen jello or tofu it's jello okay the
wines got them to me okay I'm gonna miss
this view here missus please I'm just
I'm so I'm kind of sad going home
because I don't want to leave this but
I'm also kind of happy going home
because I miss I miss my babies Isaac
took Kitty but you know to be perfect if
we could just bring everyone here and it
would be like dreamland and then this
funny cuz I see a lot of comments like
you guys gonna make your baby now that
you got the traveling editor system
[Music]
I'm just kidding I still there's still a
lot of things I want to see but this
entire vacation three weeks you've been
off especially ending it with Istria
like this has been perfect like I'm just
like man what more can I ask for but you
know you can always have more I'm so
greedy I mean you two you say you want
to see the world's not just me like
people you people got to hear your
perspective too because they only see it
for me I come out like picking up like
this like princess that wants everything
when you want it to and you got talk I
do on him yeah like I want to travel to
like the types of traveling is gonna be
less exotic and less further away unless
luxurious I guess there's a lot of
things haven't consider when you travel
with the baby it's a give-and-take and
so I'm quite happy traveling the world
with you right now in full of the
different locations that we've been
through so far and and hopefully many
more I think another thing that is very
easily forgotten as the fact that back
at home like we're 100% on our own as
soon as we bring a kid into the picture
it's just us and that's it like we don't
have family members nearby that can
really we can really rely on with Isaac
like it's been really easy and
awesome because we do have his dad that
is really involved in his life and the
three of us really work together to be
like a parent team so the food pretty
much does all three of us were pretty
much part-time parents like none of us
are like full full-time parents because
Isaac is in school he spends most of
most of the week in school by time like
the weekend comes around like sometimes
antenna that's the like it's just the
fact that we don't have him 24/7
once we have a kid a new kid it's gonna
be like all the time and only I don't
know I don't think you know what you're
trying to send it for because I know
I've been there but that's why I'm
trying to prolong this is happily
newlywed marry vacation life as long as
I can this trip has been awesome annoys
and I think
like the baby theory huh and I'm just so
conflicted right now but then a lot of
people tell me who cares you've got a
lot of time and you're still really
young there's nothing to rush like yeah
that's true too but I think seeing Isaac
grow up as an only child like four more
years he has three minutes of going and
it makes me feel a little guilty and I
wish I came to my siblings but anyway
yes and enjoy this less of you really be
ready had breakfast
when is waiting for them to pick us up
we're gonna enjoy the last few hours in
istria and three hour ride back to
Sondra and flying out there going
spending the night in Istanbul and then
we finally get home
[Music]
it's raining the whole time we've been
here it's been gorgeous weather is
bright sunny days and now the day that
we leave
history is crying like no don't leave
guys so now we're at the restaurant yeah
this place is famous world's Guinness
Book of Records whatever the title is
the point is they found the world's
biggest white truffle back in the
nineties so now we're gonna have our
last truffle meal
[Music]